hi in this video we're going to talk
about wrasse which is a monomeric
g-protein now whenever we talk about
g-proteins the picture that comes to our
mind is the g-protein coupled receptor
signaling where we talked about the
trimeric g-protein which have a G alpha
beta and gamma subunit but other than
these trimeric format of g-protein there
are quite a lot of G protein which are
monomeric such as the wrasse wrasse is
one of the component of map kinase
signaling pathway and wrasse has
important implications in terms of
physiology so in this video we are going
to learn all about wrasse its mechanism
of action and how it is important in
terms of physiology so let's begin
wrasse is a GTP hydrolyzing protein so
it needs GTP for its function in a gtp
bound state the wrasse is on in a gtp
bound state the wrasse is interacting
with the switch one and switch two
headaches in such a way that it looks
like a closed claw of a crab but when
gtp is hydrolyzed and the phosphate
phosphate is gone in that situation
there is a rapid conformational change
and the switch hellicksen's to move away
from each other and in this conformation
wrasse is inactive so let's look at at
which physiological level Raph's works
and how it works as a component of the
map kinase signaling pathway so map
kinase signaling pathway is very
important but before that we need to
understand that like wrasse there are
many many proteins which are falling
under the category of monomeric G
protein such as ro such as RAC and many
more and they have a diverse family now
the map kinase signaling pathway starts
with the receptor tyrosine kinase and
the most important part of the receptor
tyrosine kinase it's a tyrosine kinase
domain which is the c-terminal domain
now upon ligand binding tyrosine kinase
domain
phosphorylate itself and several sh2
domain containing protein binds to the
phosphotyrosine residue
one such sh2 domain containing protein
is GRB 2 which is the initiator in case
of the wrasse map kinase signaling
pathway ultimately another protein
called SOS binds to GRB 2 which is a
guanosine nucleotide exchange factor gif
now gif helps in the activation of
wrasse now wrasse once activated it
activates another protein which is known
as RAF RAF is a kinase RAF in a
sequential fashion activates make arc
and RSK
and ultimately it would result in gene
transcription and many of these target
genes are actually cell cycle control
genes such as see make and cyclin d1 so
clearly we can assume that these Raths
map kinase pathway can ultimately give
rise to a growth or cellular division
kind of phenotypes now it has been seen
that Raths can induce cell division in
those cell lines which does not divide
such as fibroblasts they divide seldom
right now once you have a dominant a
constitutively active version of wrasse
which is always active which cannot
hydrolyze the gtp if you transfer the
cell lines with this kind of wrasse then
what happens these cell lines start
dividing rapidly which is unusual for a
fibroblast that means wrasse can
ultimately lead to cell division via
augmenting the map kinase pathway which
is a cell division promoting pathway now
it is important to understand why this
kind of situation is happening even if
you are not providing growth media
direct growth factor directly in the
media whenever wrasse is present in a
constitutive active fashion the
signaling the flux through the signaling
pathway is flowing and ultimately the
wrasse is giving rise to gene gene
transcriptions which are ultimately
helping in cell division that
is found as an oncogene and it is
associated with many many cancer in fact
if you transfect a cell normal cell with
a constitutive active rest trans gene
the cell would convert into cancer cell
an uncontrolled growth would be formed
that means Rass is an important unko
protein as well but the question is how
the rass was discovered and how rass was
found to be a component of the map
kinase signaling pathway and there is an
interesting story and the story came
from drosophila in drosophila the eyes
are compound eyes so each units are
known as or materia and there are eight
photoreceptor cell and ended in a
specific area depicted here now in case
of a specific mutant known as seven less
or bride of seven this mutant the map
the seven less actually encodes for a
map a receptor tyrosine kinase and the
development of these are seven
photoreceptor cells are actually taking
place via map kinase signaling pathway
now in these mutant background were
scientist and what happens is like in
case of the seven list mutant there are
no map kinase pathway right because the
receptor is mutated how the signaling
would flow so definitely in the 7s
mutant when the when scientists over
express this constitutive active version
of rass what happens is very interesting
it rescues the phenotype and all the
developmental defect is corrected that
means wrasse can allow the signaling to
flow despite of the receptor is
defective or the ligand is not present
wrasse is capable of map kinase
signaling to flow and this allows the
development of the photoreceptor pigment
and that is how it was figured out that
RAF was actually involved in the map
kinase pathway so that is all about your
ass I hope you enjoyed this video
thumbs up don't forget to Like share and
subscribe thank you